in the latest episode of Attack on Titan
Falco revealed that his draw Titan could
probably fly and I'm going to explain
why earlier in the season Falco consumed
some of the Beast Titan spinal fluid
meaning that when he became a Titan
shifter he naturally gained some of the
Beast Tyson's characteristics according
to Annie this is a thing that usually
happens when one of the nine Titans
consumes a part of the other and in
Falco's case because he had the Beast
Titan's DNA inside him he became this
weird hybrid his bird-like
characteristics include claws feathers a
beak so yeah it kind of makes sense that
he'd be able to fly as well